Поправки до Третього Енергопакету ЄС,
які пропонує внести Єврокомісія,
можуть докорінно змінити ситуацію зі спорудженням "Північного потоку-2".
Зокрема, в Брюсселі хочуть розширити поняття "інтерконнектор".
Єврокомісія хоче включити у нього
не лише трубопроводи, що з‘єднують
газотранспортні системи країн ЄС,
але й ті магістралі,
що ведуть з третіх країн до ЄС.
На практиці це означатиме, що проект
"Північний потік-2" також підпаде під дію
газового законодавства ЄС,
а саме Третього енергопакета.
Таким чином,  Єврокомісія хотіла би
збільшити транспарентність, а також
забезпечити рівний доступ
усім учасникам ринку до всіх трубопроводів.
У Брюсселі вважають, що проект "Північний потік-2"
не сприяє диверсифікації джерел поставок енергоносіїв,
а, навпаки, може дозволити одному постачальнику
іще більше посилити свої позиції на ринку газу ЄС.
Очевидно, мається на увазі Росія.
Якщо "Північний потік-2" все ж збудують,
то Єврокомісія хотіла би щонайменше подбати про прозорість
його експлуатації та щоб він відповідав
усім правилам енергетичного ринку ЄС.
Газопровід має пройти з Росії до Німеччини
дном Балтійського моря.
Ключове значення у його реалізації має позиція Берліна.
Він вважає цей проект виключно економічним,
який реалізують приватні компанії.
Такий підхід фактично відкриває можливість
безперешкодного будівництва "Північного потоку-2".
Оскільки його планують прокласти дном Балтійського моря
напряму з Росії до Німеччини, де він і завершиться,
впливати на ного Євросоюз не може.
Такий висновок юридичної службиРади ЄС.
Водночас офіційна Варшава, яка бачить
у "Північному потоці-2" загрозу,
упевнена, що це сфера дії  норм ЄС.
Юридичний висновок Польщі чи Ради ЄС -
чия ж позиція переможе?